tout le monde sait depuis longtemps
qu'une élection le 3 octobre
saphique tous les partis politiques sont
sur un pied d'égalité si on doit même
atteint on change la loi picon
d'une campagne électorale de cinq
semaines b si on dit faut pas que de
publicité ou entre coco ligue que les
coûts soit
tenu compte dans les dix semaines avant
ben je vous prédis qu'il ya du monde
pour voir la publicité 11 semaines avant
ces crèmes en outre est ce qu'on la lit
qui est important son suicide façon
religieuse c'est quand la publicité
partisane ceux payés à 100% par le parti
dans notre corps date par la cac
alors françois legault vous venez de
l'entendre a été interrogé aujourd'hui
sur la pertinence des très nombreuses et
publicité de la cac en période pré
électorale parce que vous savez les
élections s'en viennent vous avez
certainement vu elles sont partout
partout pourtant la campagne n'est même
pas encore commencé la caq tirent profit
d'un flou semble-t-il dans la loi
électorale sur les dépenses de
précampagne regarder les chiffres pour
les réseaux sociaux d'avril à juillet le
parti de françois legault a dépensé
presque autant que les quatre autres
partis réunis ces publicités en val tels
les dépenses et doivent-elles être
encadrés comme l'a exprimé le directeur
général des élections pierre reid et là
quelques jours on aurait voulu l'inviter
à l'émission mais il a voulu respecter
son devoir de réserve de neutralité
ce sera
à un moment donné son rôle de souhaiter
des réformes on a deux très bons invités
avec nous mais vrai que prince
correspondante parlementaire à québec
lui rené quand même qui a fait une passe
de 20 spécialistes et aussi sur le
discours politique en effet votre
maîtrise là dessus alors on est très
contents de vous avoir avec nous un
véronique et puis jean jacques stréliski
professeur associé à hec montréal et
spécialiste en stratégie de l'image y en
a vu beaucoup jean-jacques c'est l'ex
qui enjambe dément alors commençons par
commenter ce que monsieur legault vient
de dire indépendamment de la nation du
mal de ses publicités
véronique l'appel
lancé à quoi nous et non pas en deux
jours par pierre reid ne semble pas
avoir été entendu
important monsieur reid souhaite
encadrer cette période pré électorale ce
pas mais tant qu'il n'y aura pas
d'encadrement mais les partis politiques
vont en profiter tous les partis
politiques et dans un sens françois
legault n'a pas tort quand il dit que
tous les partis peuvent en profiter oui
et non je vais d'abord vous dire oui et
vous expliquer pourquoi ses pas et qu
après oui parce que une campagne
d'élections à date fixe comme ça ça
permet une certaine prévisibilité ans
tous les partis profite de cette
prévisibilité prévisibilité là qui leur
donne vraiment une facilité au niveau du
recrutement par exemple ils peuvent
commencer leur campagne un an avant a
commencé à recruter des candidats qui
pour la plupart ont déjà un emploi
doivent annoncer leur démission c'est
plus facile de dire à partir de telle
date annoncera sa démission parce que de
toute façon la campagne peut être
déclenchée au plus tard le 29 ou aussi
ça leur permet déjà lancé leurs
plateformes le parti libéral en lancer
la sienne au mois de juin éric duhaime
port en campagne électorale dimanche une
semaine avant le temps il a envoyé une
communication médias pour dire que lui
sa campagne il l'a déclenchée le
dimanche le 21 ou ensuite dessous ça
permet évidemment aux partis politiques
de préparer leur budget leur cagnotte
électorale de tester leur ligne leurs
messages des semaines même des mois à
l'avancé là où il n'y a pas d'égalité
contrairement à ce que dit françois
legault c'est que c'est certain que le
parti au pouvoir peut effectuer des
dépenses publicitaires plus importante
des mois al avance en économie en
finance en éducation ils peuvent se
bâtir un budget préélectoral au mois de
mars précédant la campagne alors c'est
clair qu'ils ont un avantage sur ses
adversaires parce qu'il est au pouvoir
quel regard portez-vous là dessus sur
cette question lorsque ces avantages de
précampagne il ya tous ces avantages
comme l'invention de madame prince et il
a aussi l'avantagé
d'être préparée très en avance je sais
qu'il ya une proportion peut-être dans
les moyens qui sont mis à disposition de
ces publicités ou des de cette publicité
préélectorale mais on sent là quatre en
tous les cas une organisation
stratégique et qui est beaucoup plus
importante et qui est justement risque
de donner aussi on verra mais je veux
dire des résultats plus probants dans la
mesure où on sept monsieur legault a
aussi les sondages pour lui donc ils se
sont dit on n'a pas échappé le ballon on
va on va y aller et tous azimuts que
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait parce qu'on les
voit on les voit partout mais sur la
question de peut-être l'iniquité entre
les parties même si monsieur leubou du
tout le monde part avec les mêmes dates
les mêmes d'information qu'est ce que
vous entendez l'inéquité elle est
comment dirais-je elle fait partie du
dossier c'est à dire aussi que c'est le
gouvernement au pouvoir si le
gouvernement qui a honte en l'occurrence
de véritablement de l'expérience et il a
effectivement plus de moyens est ce que
c'est inéquitable c'est pas à nous de le
dire c'est véritablement et la dame
prince l'a souligné au règlement au
compte qu'on doit changer pour essayer
de préciser en tous les cas le rôle de
la publicité en période pré-électorale
et c'est ce qui n'est pas fait pour le
moment ce qui permet au gouvernement et
à la cat d'exploiter ce flou artistique
si vous l'étiez qui est probant donsey
en cette matière yannick mais en même
temps est-ce que c'est efficace cette
publicité préélectorale où on risque
d'ennuyer les gens trop rapidement
véronique en fait dans le cas de
françois legault ou pendant les deux
dernières années je dirais c'était
principalement des messageries à la
pandémie qu'il livrait là donc c'était
pour toujours des bonnes nouvelles on
s'entend même que la majorité du temps
c'était les mauvaises nouvelles alors la
publicité dans son corps permet non
seulement de consolider des acquis mais
permet aussi d'essayer de protéger
d'autres acquis qui sont plus à risque
on pense à la région de québec où l'oeil
à un discours les gens commencent à être
intéressés peut-être à entendre ce qu
éric duhaime dit par exemple voilà les
publicités de françois legault vre sont
peut-être plus visible dans la région de
québec à ce moment là c'est ce point que
son équipe s cibler davantage certaines
régions comme ça aussi françois legault
comme n'importe quel chiffre de
gouvernement doit monter montrer son
côté un peu plus givré un donc de
montrer son son côté plus joyeux aller à
la rencontre des gens ce qu'il n'a pas
pu faire pendant les dernières années
videmment avec la pandémie donc les
publicités lui permettent de montrer ce
côté et le tue le recours aux réseaux
sociaux parce que c'est là l'omni
présence sur les réseaux sociaux en quoi
ça s'améliore ou s'associer les
stratégies de campagne mais en faveur de
qui je crois que c'est indispensable
aujourd'hui les médias sociaux 1 jouent
un rôle prépondérant dans les campagnes
parce que tout le monde ne l'a pas
premièrement la télévision et que
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui sont des
adeptes des médias sociaux donc le joue
un rôle prépondérant
maintenant il faut regarder que à
l'intérieur il faut regarder aussi ce
qui va se faire à l'intérieur de chaque
parti politique parce qu'on a beaucoup
parlé du cas de deux lacs la tène
monsieur legault mais il ya aussi que
dans les autres quand il ya des
stratégies qui sont en train de se
développer on voit ça et là des messages
on voit ça et là sur les médias sociaux
justement certains candidats qu'ils se
prononcent sur certaines questions
importantes et là on sent nettement
le là encore un écart entre la
préparation de la cac la préparation des
autres partis quand on a un tableau en
quelques mots on peut le voir peut-être
le tableau est en même temps c est ce
que c'est un salon une question de
moyens selon vous jean-jacques il ya les
autres partis se disent on ne dépensera
pas d'argent là parce qu'en campagne ça
va être plus important peut-être que
c'est c'est de l'argent gaspillé avant
la capelle je ne sais pas si c'est bien
l'argent gaspillé je ne vous dirai pas
comme ça en tous les cas ce que ce que
je sais c'est que effectivement est lié
à la stratégie des moyens il salue
incontournablement la caq a plus les
moyens c'est évident et d'un autre côté
il ya véritablement là la vraie
stratégie de communication tandis celle
des contenus et c'est là où justement
monsieur legault est attendue je pense
en campagne et il sera attendu à la fois
dans les publicités mais sera surtout
attendu dans les débats parce qu'il ya
des grandes questions qui pour l'instant
sont absentes de toute publicité si vous
prenez la question de l'environnement
aujourd'hui bon il ya eu la sphère de la
fonderie horne dont vous venez de parler
mais pour l'instant il ya encore des
grands enjeux des qu'elle n'a pas été
adressée actuellement dans la danse à
son pré électorale et qui devront l'être
nécessairement hélas les autres
candidats des autres partis attendent
ensuite j'aime je pense à une stratégie
lui est très présent sur facebook une
fois par semaine - depuis peu moins de
publicité pour l'anecdote seulement pour
montrer des fois ça déborde on a vu la
dame âgée en début qui avait provoqué
une controverse
mais hier je cherchais une publicité où
7 candidats devront faire va l'écouter
pour l'anecdote mais ça montre des fois
que ça déborde parce que la caq leur
retirer cette publicité là on a capté
sur un écran
[Musique]
marche pas encore mais ça venait et puis
dans la soirée ma fille c'est bien
marcher battre en politique
cet avis de
déportation
[Musique]
qui
véronique mais écoutez c'est sûr qu'une
publicité comme cela c'était planifié
par la coalition américain beck donc il
ya quelqu'un dans l'équipe publicitaire
kddi est c'est bon c'est extrait là
qu'est la vie
c'est celui le concours ont enlevé dans
la publicité donc il savait probablement
que ça allait faire réagir en même temps
ils ont testé jusqu'où ça faisait réagir
se sont aperçus que web ça passe
peut-être un peu moins bien c'est pas
grave on l'a retirée on en a d'autres
parce que les des vox pop comme ça ils
en ont fait des dizaines avec des gens
et là ils ont les archives ils peuvent
dire non mais celui là qu'on va sortir à
la place du tour quand même d'autres
possibilités mais en même temps une
publicité comme celle là se connaissant
même publicité négative alors à la
limite ils auront fait jaser 2 pendant
48 heures ça aura roulé sur les réseaux
sociaux pour complètement mauvais non
plus jeanjean non c'est pas mauvais bien
entendu c'est un petit peu anecdotique
quand nous convient et le ton après le 7
mars
est ce qu'on dirait que c'est un miracle
que monsieur legault arrive de faire
marche sur les autres mais ma sur les
eaux comme l'écrit
ça peut être dangereux de déborder ou 5
sur absolument à d'ailleurs ils ont bien
fait de la retirer ils l'ont bien faible
l'autre chose qui m'apparaît important
que madame france l'a mentionné ils
appellent ça des vox pop oui et il le
fait d'appeler ça des vox pop ça permet
de parler un peu des publicités oui vous
êtes
à oui c'est vraiment un afférents les
gens éprouvent et rené quand tu es en
quelques secondes vous y croyez à
l'impact la publicité j'y crois pour
certaines générations certaines tranches
d'âge certain public et c'est pourquoi
justement la coalition amr québec a
investi beaucoup dans les réseaux
sociaux on voit qu'aujourd'hui en 2028
toutes sortes de façons de faire de la
publicité et je pense que les partis
politiques sont en train justement
d'explorer toutes ces façons là pour
rejoindre et
différentes générations comme je devais
essayer de les faire sortir pour aller
voter ainsi ce label est un comble pour
des stratégies publicitaires ce soir on
viendra certainement sur le contenu de
ces publicités éventuellement véronique
ce jour un plaisir de vous accueillir à
24,60 jean-jacques également jean
jacques stréliski consisterait à ceux-ci
de celle et sa stratégie bonsoir à tous
les deux bonsoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit